Vicky is with us in Columbus Ohio hi
Vicki how are you I'm doing great how
are you Dave better than I deserve
what's up thanks for watch for taking my
call I have a question I'm I'm in about
a month away from being finished with
baby step number two and I'm 40 I'm 40
years old and I have two daughters on 16
and 14 I have not been able to save any
money for their college because of for
repeat court appearances with their
father um and I feel like I want to be
able to help it at the same time I'm
also afraid about my own future with
regard to retirement so my question is
how would you recommend kind of doing
the best of both worlds where while I'm
phasing into you know four or five or
six
gotcha what's your income I'm about
eighty thousand a year well that's great
news okay cool how much does your house
payment uh 860 oh good very reasonable
okay so you get on this budget and you
start saying okay I'm going to start
doing something towards retirement and
baby step four and you know we recommend
15% there you may or may not go that
heavy because you got to write up at
college age and then but you start
throwing some serious Bank aside for the
kids and we start talking to them
they're 13 and 16 and there's four or
five things that you need to be doing
when it comes to going to college when
you're broke and here's how you do it
number one mistake people make is they
choose a college they can't afford and
very very few jobs less than two or
three percent of jobs care where you
went to school they just care that you
learn something and it may be you got
the degree while you're learning
something right and so I mean I've never
gone to a doctor and went now wait a
minute for you take my kidney out
where'd you go to school I've never done
that you know I've never heard I've
never hired a lawyer no it not you can't
sue that guy because you didn't go that
right school I'm not gonna let you sue
him for me okay
I actually address that with my oldest
already so I think we're okay and she
should fixated on in spades I think
don't got that covered so we're fixed
fixated on in-state that's a good thing
so in-state tuition
one maybe even year one is community
college which is a fourth the cost and
you knock out the the basics you know
the the the English comp class and the
basic in a foreign language or whatever
it is she's in there entering in to
knock them out for just pennies on the
dollar maybe you're one so College
choice is the biggest thing in the
equation because as you have already
discovered in-state is half of
out-of-state and it's 1/4 of private or
maybe an eighth per depending on which
private we're talking about ok so that
that's that's the thing then the second
thing is they need to become experts at
taking the a CT and SAT our kids took it
and then took a class on how to take it
afterwards we spent a couple hundred
bucks with a tutor they went back and
took it again and every one of them
every time they did that their points or
their scores went up which does two
things one is it gets them admitted to
the school they got to have a high
enough score to actually get in the
second thing is a quality the higher the
score obviously the more they're
qualified for scholarships which brings
us to the third thing their full-time
job is filling out essays and
applications for free money to go to
school and you know I want them to like
have a thousand applications out before
they head off to school I met one lady
not long ago I heard she was single mom
just like you she made her daughter fill
out applications and she literally did a
thousand she got turned down for like
over nine hundred of them zero Wow but
the rest of them gave her $38,000 so she
went to school free and she lived at
home okay you know so that that's not a
bad job I mean you fill out a form and
it takes you and 30 minutes to fill out
a form and do an essay and you know you
get 1 out of 10 of those comes back
maybe and turns into some money and you
get $200 I mean how many other places
can a sixteen-year-old make $200 an hour
you know so that's a great plan there so
getting the a CT scores up applying for
scholarships oh and plan on working
while you're in college right I did I
did did you
I actually yes I did yes most of us debt
but that this generation is decided
that's child abuse it's not child abuse
as a matter of fact I would prefer as an
employer to hire somebody that worked
while they were in school because they
actually have a degree and they know how
to work and so I actually look at that
did they work their way through school
as a huge plus when I'm hiring a young
person coming in here I look at that and
so they're somewhere I'm by doing it is
there somewhere that you would recommend
that we go eight that we go to get list
of available scholarships are no there's
not a difference I have not been able to
find a credible single source and so we
just tell you to wear Google out if we
ever find a credible single source I'll
make them rich by endorsing them and you
know and millions of people will be
going to that same site so but you know
it's you know it's just it's a needle in
the haystack thing is what you're doing
but it's okay because it's free stinking
money so they're going to work they're
going to work and oh by the way their
GPA while they're in school is a big
deal too right
and are you guys involved in your church
I know we're actually not overly active
with the church okay if they're involved
in other community activities be
documenting those the the citizenship
angle on getting the scholarships is a
big deal they work you know they work at
the homeless shelter here there they do
this whatever it is they do that they do
for others and it proves their you know
the quality of their character as young
ladies the good news is this when
they're in school
go nanny you make 20 bucks an hour nanny
right babysit grow babysitting make 20
bucks an hour I know people paying 20
bucks an hour to babysit and and guess
what that's always it's almost always a
night or in afternoons or you work
around your school and that kind of
stuff and say they can make serious Bank
and work their way on through and guess
what you got a few years that you make a
good income you're going to be able to
help some too
so all of this starters together to call
to be called a debt free experience in
college I don't last pieces this make
sure they're studying something that is
actually usable in the marketplace we
don't need a degree in left handed
puppetry okay
so really really good question and you
got it Vicki you can do it but you're
just going to have to be very
intentional about all of those different
things and all of those pieces come
together to form a puzzle and it's a
beautiful picture it's a beautiful thing
and it'll work and people go to school
debt-free all the time and that's how
they do it you know but can you go to a
$50,000 a year school no not when you're
broke but you can't drive a $50,000 car
either when you're broke so that's not
it's not a different idea you know you
just you do what you can afford
champagne tastes for your pocketbook you
know how it works so you just decide
these things and but education is the
only thing that people are stupid about
which is to me the paradox the funniest
paradox in our culture today people are
stupid about education I just dumped
about education and they lose their
minds over it they justify it in their
head that I can do this and I can use it
200 thousand dollars in student loan
debt good gracious don't do that stuff
people this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you enjoyed
that video from the Dave Ramsey show if
you want to watch another great video
check out my video three things you
should consider renting right over here
or click the link in the description
below